we're going to be talking about the new
ways to treat covid in the future
yesterday a group of experts gathered at
the white house to talk exactly that
about the state of this pandemic dr
celine gallander was there she's a cbs
news contributor and editor-at-large at
kff's kaiser health news and joins us to
fill us on what was discussed but before
we think about the old the new ways
let's talk about the old ways for just a
second because celine when we first got
the vaccine everybody thought it was a
superpower we don't have to worry
because that's normally what vaccines do
then we're told you got to get a second
vaccine then we're told you got to get a
booster then we're told you got to get a
second booster and then you still get it
so how do you explain how we're supposed
to process this i think that's part of
the vaccine fatigue i think that's part
of the frustration i think on some level
we over promised what the vaccines could
do i think people thought they would
prevent all infections they would
prevent transmission in fact most
vaccines are not really designed to do
that most vaccines are designed to
prevent severe disease hospitalization
and death so preventing you from getting
really sick
and so what people have realized is oh
i'm still getting an infection um you
know why is this happening despite
the vaccination the key is that they are
keeping you out of the hospital but
people didn't really understand what
they were supposed to do yeah i think if
we had been told that then our
expectations it was the messaging that
was the messaging because honest to god
when i got i thought i have a superpower
i'm good all right so now as we sit here
today we keep hearing about a new
vaccine that's coming in the fall will
we will that vaccine be the one that
just solves all of the covet problems
for us or does it is it just targeted
for one type of variant so what we're
getting in the fall is being updated for
the omicron ba-5 variant so that's the
one that you're seeing across the
country
now exactly he probably has ba5
the issue though is we know variants
continue to emerge the virus continues
to mutate so we don't know even by this
fall ba-5 may not be the variant we may
have something else and we're kind of
chasing our tails right now trying to
keep up with the virus by the time we
figure out there's a new variant develop
an updated vaccine we might already be
on to a new variant so will it be
possible to have one vaccine that covers
all the variants no matter what form
they take so this is what will it take
that's a good question yeah so that's
one of the technologies we were
discussing at the white house yesterday
in terms of vaccine advancement it's
what we would call say a universal
chronovirus vaccine so it's trying to
target a part of the virus that doesn't
mutate as much
figuring out what that is and still
getting a vaccine that creates a good
immune response that protects you is a
little bit of a challenge and it is
going to require more resources just
like we had operation speed
it is money it is money so just like
operation warp speed poured in a ton of
money to try to expedite the development
of the original coronavirus vaccines if
you want these faster it's going to cost
more money but but doctor it was going
back to gail's point i mean if we've
received the vaccine then the second one
and then the two boosters and we're not
going to hospital and we're not going
ending up in an icu or worse you're not
compromised you're not compromised if i
get another vaccine it's the same thing
right in other words i could still be
infected
but i wouldn't be sick enough to go to
the hospital so why not just say most
americans are going to say well i'm good
yeah because i'm getting i'm healthy i'm
getting infected and it was just a
sniffle and it's doing what it said but
i don't need another vaccine if the
results are that i can still be in fact
get it yeah yeah
we don't know that it's going to
continue to be that way that they will
continue to hold up and we've seen
especially with delta and then omicron
we are seeing especially the elderly
right now ending up a bit more in the
hospital even if they've had you know
two three doses of vaccine which is also
why we're telling them to get you know
that fourth dose
and whether we'll continue to see that
erosion um in the immunity that you get
from these vaccines we don't know yet
but we do anticipate they may have more
and more trouble protecting us yeah
earlier you mentioned um vaccine
advancement in technology you have
something um
so this is a skin patch it has tiny
microscopic needles so you can't even
see them on here
it kind of feels them
can't really even feel them no that's
for a vaccine that's for a vaccine so
you have dry vaccine embedded in these
micro needles and then you take it off
kind of like you would a band-aid
and you stick it on your arm just like
that and you leave it on for a couple
few days and it's delivering the vaccine
into your skin self-application vaccine
you could even do that i mean
theoretically you could have your doctor
mailing you one of these you know that
would replace an injection yeah this
would replace an injection and when you
take a bath what happens
um good question um i have not asked
them that i would suspect you probably
want to cover it so it doesn't fall off
yeah but um i'm not sure i'll trust
myself
or trust the technology to be honest
with them right i'm just not sure yeah
me too yeah i mean it's a pretty new
technology where we haven't used it
really for other vaccines yet but i
think there's a lot of promise not just
for covet but for other vaccines other
vaccines okay dr flynn gallander thank
you so much you're the best